I think POI hybrids are amongst the
coolest POI tricks out there and like
most people I do have my favorites and I
want to share them with you Drex here
from drexfactor POI sharing with you the
love of poi spinning and flow Arts to
benefit your body and brain and today I
want to break down my top 10 favorite
hybrids and share them with you but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I've got down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel Becca
beckonen thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so POI hybrids are a type of poi
trick that involves essentially doing a
mashup up between two very different
types of poi patterns but getting them
to sync up it's a really really cool
idea and it produces some incredibly
cool visuals I've done tons of videos
over the years breaking down various POI
hybrids and how to do them but I feel
like I've never really done a good video
showcasing my favorites among that class
of poi tricks and do bear in mind that
this is a rabbit hole that goes pretty
deep I did an entire video several years
back explaining both the basic concept
behind hybrids as well as some of the
various permutations of them which is
going to cover a lot of vocabulary that
I'm going to be going through in this
video so if you haven't already watched
it you should go check that out I'll
include a link down in the description
as well as up in the cards if you're
watching on YouTube so I hope you will
forgive me here if I get a little bit
self-indulgent and play favorites
because well there are definitely some
POI hybrids that hit me in a different
way than many others and here they are
starting off I've got to give props and
yes pun intended to the granddaddy of
all POI hybrids that is isolation versus
extension now of course the first
version of this that was discovered had
the hands together it was discovered by
Andy house way back in the day but I
have to admit I'm a little bit more
partial to having the hands apart in an
alignment that would eventually become
known as an anti-red alignment and yes
that will become very important as we go
on and discover more hybrids in this
list
the classic the original and still one
of my favorites
[Music]
on this list they're both going to be
taken up by what on paper is exactly the
same portrait but expressed in vastly
different ways that would be four petal
anti-spin flower versus two petal inspin
flower and this particular version of it
is with the hands in Split time
opposites while the POI are in Split
Time same direction part of what I like
about this is that it keeps the timing
and Direction consistent between both
the hands and the POI and creates these
lovely little moments where it appears
that the poiers squeezing together on
either end I'm also a big fan of using
this as a setup for doing plane breaks
as well as breaking into Buzz soft
flowers and a bunch of other different
options really you can see me doing this
in a bunch of my flow videos I'm a huge
fan
next up on the list is you guessed it
four pedal anti-spin versus two petal
and spin and specifically A variation
that turns this into a body Tracer it's
sometimes called the nevisole and named
after a Swedish POI Spinner by the name
of Thomas Johansson or as his nickname
was back in the day nevisole part of
what I love about this is that it has a
lot of level changes built into it so it
works really well with dance and also
too it doesn't hurt that it also makes
for interesting transitions into things
like windmills as well as four beat
fountains and a variety of other tricks
plus which this integrates super well
into Archer weave fountains so it makes
for some great body tracing transitions
as well
[Music]
ha
foreign next up we start getting into
polyrhythm hybrid land and we start that
off with the POI hybrid that launched a
thousand Facebook profile photos that is
the Mercedes or is it would more
technically be known extension versus
three petal anti-spin one of the first
polyrhythm hybrids to be identified the
history of this move goes back at least
a decade and a half not only does it
create an absolutely beautiful set of
trails that create really really awesome
long exposure photos it was also a key
move in learning how to go back and
forth between different timing and
directions as on top the POI are
spinning in together opposites and on
bottom they're spinning in Split time
opposites this became a really important
stepping stone for people figuring out
how to accurately shift between
different timing and Direction modes not
only does it look beautiful it's super
useful as well
[Music]
and next up it's close sibling pendulum
versus triquetra now I'll confess to
having some mixed feelings about putting
this one on the list just because
technically speaking both of the
patterns buried inside of it aren't
actually individual POI patterns but
caps and therefore are Composites of
multiple POI patterns after all that
triquetra is actually the bottom half of
a box mode for petal anti-spin flower
and the top half of a linear isolation
whereas that pendulum is the bottom of
an extension and the top part of a
linear isolation in and of itself just
one that goes horizontally but
terminology notwithstanding this was one
of the most fashionable POI hybrids to
learn about a decade ago it has that
great moment up top where it looks like
you're going through a little bit of a
cat eye and we have that really really
beautiful bit where the two POI
essentially work as one line going
across the top before breaking into
polyrhythms on the bottom there's a lot
going for this pattern don't get me
wrong I love it to this day
oh
foreign
remember how earlier I said that
anti-brids were going to come to be an
important part of this list well we have
officially arrived with our first entry
pendulum versus cap this to my mind is
still the foundational anti-bred yes
even more so than the hands apart
version of isolation versus extension if
for no other reason then this is kind of
the Rosetta Stone of anti-brids just
about any other anti-bird that you can
possibly think of can transition in and
out of this particular pattern it's also
foundational because so many of the
concepts around anti-brids including the
alignment of the hands and POI as well
as the ability to reach around the kind
of buzzsaw plane that we keep the core
pattern for anti-brid Zen all are easily
learned with this pattern gravity is
helping you out every single way along
it and that doesn't happen in most other
anti-brid patterns really important for
beginners and it still looks cool
[Music]
and next up the anti-brid that I
personally think is even cooler than the
Mercedes that is static spin versus
triquetra there's a lot of reasons why I
like this move a lot more one of which
being that I just think the alignment of
the hand and POI kind of adds an
additional layer of interest to this
that doesn't happen in Mercedes but also
quite frankly because I think it Bears
more of a resemblance to the original
Celtic artwork that we get Trey catchers
from that and this is one of those
classic POI patterns where I think it
actually does work better if you perform
it faster a great way to get your
audience engaged and especially if
you're doing it with LED or fire to get
your audience to see the full pattern
that you're creating with the POI by
whipping through it real fast
[Music]
and next up a POI trick that is still a
major Flex for me that is isolation
versus horizontal cat eye when I first
learned how to do this there could not
have been more than a dozen people in
the world that could perform it and I
felt hugely accomplished when I got it
down I'm not going to lie as Tech boy
became more accessible in the mid to
late 2010s I expected that everybody was
going to learn how to do this that it
was going to become as commonplace as
the Mercedes and I was shocked when that
didn't happen still to this day it's
very rare that you can find people that
can do this trick let alone do it
cleanly if you're down for the challenge
yourself I have done a tutorial on it
I'll go ahead and link to that down
below in the description but for the
time being I'm also going to still say
that I enjoy this getting to be a flex
all right so we are down to our final
two tricks on the list and they're both
going to be Gunslinger based tricks but
before we get to them I have a favor to
ask now if you've come this far I'm
going to guess that it means that you
think POI spinning is cool maybe you're
looking for information on specific POI
tricks or you just like the flow arts in
general which if any of these are true
of you then guess what I make tons of
videos on all of these different topics
so if you wouldn't mind go ahead and
give the video a like And subscribe to
the channel so you know when I drop a
new video thanks in advance all right so
let's dive back in with so this right
here is an isolation versus a six pedal
Gunslinger this is a trick that I
actually picked up from an old John
Alvarez video but notice that he wasn't
doing it particularly cleanly so I
decided that I was going to clean it up
and try and make it my own and quite
frankly I think I did a great job of
that which fun fact you can think of
this as being the corollary and
Gunslinger world of isolation versus cat
eye I did a whole video on that back in
the day that'll go ahead and link to
down in the description but this is
definitely one of those that I like
busting out especially on fire if I have
led handles to really wow the audience
and make them wonder what exactly is
going on there
[Music]
and for the final trick on this list we
have static spin versus 10 pedal
Gunslinger in the same way that
isolation versus six petal Gunslinger is
kind of the Gunslinger correlation of
isolation versus cat eye this move right
here is the Gunslinger correlation with
static spin versus triquetra this one I
particularly like because it combines
together a pattern that I already kind
of like and makes it a lot bigger and
also adds in the element of Gunslingers
wherein you have one of the POI spinning
very very very fast to create a really
complex pattern in my mind this move is
a modern classic and I really wish I saw
more people out there doing it hey maybe
you could pick it up so those were my
picks for my 10 favorite POI hybrids
what are your favorites please leave me
a comment and let me know
[Music]
thank you
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out some of the
other videos that I have done on POI
hybrids over the years I will go ahead
and leave a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen if you are watching on
YouTube thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today
yourself and I'll see you with a new
video real soon take care
peace